hi John how are you what's going on John
C McKinley you guys again good to see
you yeah how are you never better
well welcome we were just talking about
uh bathroom habits of rich Voss over
here he's very
I mean he's disgusting you know what
they are they're just they've tried to
build themselves up by tearing people
down but I don't do that you know what I
mean that's exactly what we do oh
nothing that's what everyone does this
every good person does yeah that's what
brothers do with each other right my
brother Jerry Mark and I and that's that
the standard operating procedure was
either knock Jerry down or knock marked
down to elevate yourself who's the
oldest I am okay so you were the you a
kind of the one that would would you
bully them at all or no when they were
very little because they became so can
you swear yeah absolutely they became so
goddamn big that you had to get your
cuts in early ok the size of a Kenmore
refrigerator now and so no there's the
everything was reconciled prior to being
10 ok get your licks in then like I used
to home you know how people used to hold
their brother down and they would spit
and suck it up and sure I would hold him
down and put my penis in his mouth I was
only two years old I should do that no
he's one of his brother to hold him down
Tony was hoping it was all used to take
my brother Marc and when we moved out of
the city and out to out towards Millburn
New Jersey we would take mark and when
trash cans used to be made out of metal
now they're all made out of plastic
stuff for 10 whatever their metal would
stick mark in a garbage can put the top
on and roll them down the driveway
first of all just making that horrible
clanking sound those old metal cans used
to make yeah that at any point in his
life come back and be like you know that
was really really we laugh about it now
well you have to I mean it was just a
Jackie ass thing to do of course what do
they do now though your brother's they
all work down in finance all they do
so you did Wall Street did that did you
they have any connection to helping you
out with that or not at all no but I
worked on the floor I worked for
Henderson Brothers as a summer job for a
couple summers so and my father worked
at Kidder Peabody and for 45 or 50 years
so none of that stuff was far removed so
when you we used two guys in the sock if
I don't really do it anymore I think
it's all computerized but when they
would be waving tickets instead do you
you you you understand what's happening
there
I have no idea how anything gets
accomplished or how anybody has track of
any how do you know what's getting in
yeah what would you be yelling like with
the guy with the tickets yelling and
like what are you looking for the guy
who's staying there writing stuff down
it's called making a market and so
you're just buying and selling whatever
the issue was it mean it'd be no
different if we were if we were making a
market and in in this thing of water and
the bid was 425 and the ask was 450 we
have to meet somewhere between 25 and 50
so how do you keep track of who has
agreed to what no idea really I think
that's all on your computer now when
there was 10 people yelling is your one
person catching it or must you know
their mother had to me does it function
in an orderly it's called an orderly
market there was an orderly market for
way before we were born
right and so I think somebody had it
figured out because I was always I
always get stressed out but the
stressful part was like how does any
what if a guy didn't catch that thing
that that guy just said like yeah then
that star never happened I think guys
caught with everything but it was an
orderly market yeah you write stuff down
and I guess hand the tea yet to have a
ticket or something that would handle
her paper yeah it's so confusing and
stressful to wash you know stock market
guys have a [ __ ] they burnout young
right they they really young burnout yes
that's why they make their money young
yeah I think that's the idea right that
you make your money and then there's
tiny then you move up to either a sales
position or a management position but
being down in the pit like in Chicago at
the mercantile they call it the pit and
I don't know how long you're you're
you're there yeah I think you're there
for a little while and then you go on to
maybe you climb the ladder whatever that
looks like sure always like to be on the
set of that film that's such a great
movie
of Wall Street yeah it was really
exciting because we were down the
Woolworth Building which is was at one
point in lower Manhattan the tallest
building it's not an apartment building
now aren't they rented I think they're
actually meant into apartments on but
it's a stunningly beautiful building
yeah it's cut from the same cloth as um
what's the the Art Deco building in
Midtown the Chrysler Building
yeah it's cut from the same cloth and so
we were shooting in the Woolworth
Building during the day and I was doing
talk radio up at the public at the
Shakespeare Festival on Lafayette Street
at night and so it was kind of the
actor's dream to have be doing a studio
film during the day and then being a hit
play and talk radio was a hit by then
with Eric Bogosian and and with the
original we created the play and so it
was a massive hit down there with this
it was in the the theater at the public
only had about 275 scene so it was the
hottest ticket Wow and so it was great
anyway you were doing to play talk radio
and you were the star you were the ghost
in character no Eric Oh Eric was always
Eric and I was his engineer I was
sending poles in your--in we call it the
tech box now you were the Travis dog yes
yes yes and so we were doing wall street
during the day correct so this is kind
of a New York actor's dream yet so how
was that set it was Nirvana it was great
Charlie and I had already spent two
weeks at not Bear Stearns somebody else
had let us work on their floor for two
weeks and so the talk radio was already
up and running it was a hit and so
during the day my day job was Wall
Street so that was as good as it gets in
Manhattan as an actor and obviously an
accomplished actor do you still have to
go up for auditions or do you get
offered apart they get offered otherwise
I don't really want to do it you won't
audition right um if it was for Marty
Scorsese or something surely special
then sure I'd go do his carpet but no
it's that ship sailed yeah if we if you
want to get together let's get together
if not if you want to play games and
definitely get someone else I've never
done a movie but if you're doing the
thing to me is that you know it's
something it's a dream but it's also
like [ __ ] you got a great gig you're
doing a play at night and then you got
to get up in the morning and go work on
Wall Street for a couple of weeks it's
gotta be
also I mean that was okay because I did
all of it with Charlie and Oliver and I
had already spent a year and a half
earlier in the Philippines doing platoon
so there was already Ken there was
practice team connective tissue and so
on Oliver the phone rang and platoon had
been a great success and he said you
know you want to do the next film with
me read it and my family been in finance
for a couple of generations and so it it
spoke to me immediately and it was a
great show a role to play Charlie's best
friend and that was a great gig and the
dates worked out and the Shakespeare
Festival accommodated me getting there
late a couple of times look when you're
doing a play you have to show up it's
called equity half-hour equities the
Union the actors Union for plays and you
have to show up a half hour early and I
like to show up a half hour so you can
do a vocal warmup and do whatever things
you have to do before you get on in
front of people and I was late a couple
of times and they were pretty great
about letting me go home how are you you
you you weren't after the play started
but you were within that half hour yeah
you're supposed to be at the theatre at
half hour and the rule is if you miss
half hour you're not going on your
understudy goes on absolutely is that
it's just the way it goes and I missed
half hour a bunch of times and they
still let me go on and so it was pretty
great but did the understudy hate you no
because I understood John Turturro and
Danny in the deep blue sea for about a
year and a half before and Danny and
deep blue sea was a play that John
Shanley wrote and John channle would go
on to win for moonstruck and so we were
down at Circle Square on on Bleecker and
John's just a bull he wouldn't go down
until he finally went to do desperately
seeking Susan a film that Madonna was in
at that time and it was a big deal and
all the New York actors wanted to be in
it and so I got to go on for John for
the weekend and I've been waiting for a
year and a half to do it and so no I
understand the life of an understudy I
understood John for a year and a half
and so I had no compunction about my
understudy doing whatever it was he was
gonna do your understudy but your
understudy knew right like even though
you were late you had this other thing
going on so he's not sitting there
getting warmed up like oh this is gonna
be my spot and then you show up I know
but I'm sure the stage manager we told
him you may be going on tonight and in
the middle of the talk radio is only a
one-act
it's about 70 minutes it's a hurricane
Eric onstage and but about 15 minutes in
I get to turn to the audience and do
this great monologue about how Eric and
Ives characters met it's about the seven
minute monologue and to New York actors
dream pinspot hits you in walked the
closest place you can walk to an
audience on a proscenium stage a thrust
stage the light cue is called down in
one so you get to go down in one a pin
spot hits you pin spots use your head
yes and you tell the story about what
happened with you and Eric emits an
actor's dream and iko iko wrote the
monologue with Eric in during rehearsal
and I got there and it was a
particularly horrible day on the set of
Wall Street and I got up there and I
walked down in one and the pinspot hit
me and I got about a minute into the
story and there was nothing there I
forgot the next line you forgot it it
wasn't there it was gone I was like I
want it in theater it's called going up
and I went up and I was there and I'm
sure it was fascinating for the audience
to see someone dying in front of them
did they know what was happening I don't
know I'm sure it was compelling to see
the human condition in panic in complete
chaos and I just stood there for I don't
know if it was 15 seconds it was a half
a minute and I sat down you just stopped
it yes because there was nothing there
was nothing there you could even you
could even grab a little line later in
the story you just had I went blank
maybe when that happens or is it sort of
like this happens to actors off stage
but you don't you don't you you can't
ad-lib your way out of it or blank it's
the only time I've done hundreds of
plays it's the only time I've ever gone
up and it wasn't the worst if I could go
up if you and I were doing a scene and
you could circle a line back and remind
me what we're doing this is a pin spot a
seven minute monologue there was nowhere
to go write and do that I surrendered do
that [ __ ] with you the next time you
went on the next night did it I didn't
go on the next night because I was so
late that night the night I went up I
think I got there ten of and like I said
you're supposed to be there for a half
hour which is 7/3
and I got there ten of and then I think
the next night Oliver didn't rat me till
I don't know this is seven minutes
before and the teamster we raced up
Lafayette Street and I got there and
people were places and right the stage
managers was like you can't and he was
right and so I didn't make any big deal
the understudy did it yeah he was fine
and that's part of it though right like
the fact that like I in that half-hour
you actually in your head get into this
play a percent and no matter how many
times you've done it that's what the
risk is right if you're not there
sure kind of mentally preparing even
though you've done this a hundred times
it just leaves very claustrophobe berry
claustrophobic 275 seat yeah hi any tiny
very off off-broadway house and the
stakes are high because it's the hottest
ticket in town
Eric was would win an Obie for it and
the stakes are high and that pin spot
hits you you come down and you tell this
great story and you forgot the story now
how do you continue on after that I know
that you don't have any like I knew my
knew it was an aberrant I knew was a one
we had a horrible day on the set and I
wasn't present when the segment that
night otherwise particularly mad that
day and everything was going wrong
lights for breaking things were going
wrong on movie sets and we didn't get
the day in other words if we had four
pages we were supposed to shoot today we
didn't get it and everybody was mad at
everybody and I carried that up to the
Shakespeare Festival with me and that
talk radio has nothing to do with that
that's that those are two different
things but how do you get back into the
play that night like when you're when
you're just going back to doing your
lines do you have to sit there and like
panic
kicks in and you just start to you start
to do what you've rehearsed and it just
goes into that pilot a little bit yeah
yes yes it's really weird the kids like
on state I blanked before onstage to
just doing stand-up and but there's
always a way out of it because again
you're not in a monologue but sometimes
you forget what connects you from one
word to the next it's not the first word
of the sentence it's the final word
that's a trick and that's what you don't
like we remember bullet points but
bullet points are always the first word
of a sentence it's never the last word
so yeah oh my god it's hard it
hard to understand that to get back to
it in that situation it would be
impossible yeah yeah about that story in
15 years yeah it's it's scary that comes
back like that yeah that panic right
absolutely because I just did I just did
a year or two ago a a revival with Al
Pacino and Bobby Cannavale II we did
Glengarry Glen yes what are you saying
that the stir that stores the drink the
in the movie it's the Ed Harris role oh
and I'm the one who makes the robbery
happen
I can't think I'm blanking on the
character right now but it's uh I know
it's not Shelly it's not Ricky Romo it's
I'm not I'll think of in a second
talking out things but but Dave was a
date us [ __ ] Bobby I saw him bullet
man without the [ __ ] without a
hat Chris Rock mother hat yeah but he
was so [ __ ] good in Boardwalk Empire
he won an Emmy for it he unbelievable
you hated him so much an actor yes the
best he's great do you know that he well
here's a sir but Bob Bobby got me a
ticket to see that because I saw the
version with Alan Alda the I heard that
was really good it was yeah it was uh
Liev Schreiber play dragon Romo and an
Alan Alda played Shelley which was so
weird to see anybody with Jack Lemmon
playing I hadn't seen that he was good
it was very good yeah but I wanted to
see
Pacino I'd never seen Pitino live and
Bobby so yeah okay he got me it and so
I'm going with my buddy that night and
it's uh you know we're getting ready
it's like six o'clock and I'm like the
plays gonna start and I think I realized
that the play was over I had overslept
it was a daytime matinee I'm a Sunday
matinee and it was the last showing
there was the last day of the play and I
thought it was a nighttime play so I
missed I would have seen your play but
I'm an ass you are that's one of my
still my greatest regrets I didn't get
to go see I didn't know you were in I
knew Bob good and I knew her bulletproof
who else was in that beside that Harbor
Richard shift jeremy Sheamus al Bobby
and me it will bulletproof so when you
go on to a play in your rehearsing
nobody knows each other yet nobody knows
anybody's energy or where you're gonna
move how long does it take to kind of
start getting things especially when I
like Pacino is there who no matter how
long you're around he's still Pacino but
we had already done any given Sunday
down in Miami no only movie and I think
owls largely why they asked me to do it
I know that's why and so the people
people lay their burden down pretty
quick out of necessity what's that mean
um you know how everybody brings in
whoever they want to be into a room yeah
and but in the rehearsal process since
we're all playing somebody else I think
people's dukes come down pretty quick so
that we can do this thing together and
we can save each other's lives on stage
right when something goes wrong like
someone goes up and we can save each
other's life in front of at the
Schoenfeld in front of 1,100 people
1,200 people who had paid to come see al
was the hottest ticket in town seeing a
land in Glengarry we're gonna have to
save each other whatever that means
something's going to go wrong and so I
think people's Dukes come down really
quick in the rehearsal hopefully in the
rehearsal process we all just go like
okay how you do this have you pulled
people have you pulled other people up
when it when you see that you can see
them blanking yes and you just kind of
bring it around and you say circle lines
just yes you know what they feel yeah
you just do it's just let me do yes
because we're out here this is we're
doing this there's 1,200 people yeah
they all paid $500 a ticket it was you
know whatever the same number is I don't
even know but yeah I'm you going to save
you I will save you I guarantee you I'll
save you that's great and nothing's
gonna go wrong when I'm around you
onstage
I'm going to save you and now we can go
someone call action we got it we're like
this and you have that same feeling from
that other person 100% what do you do if
you don't have that there's got to be
times over you will you work with
somebody right yeah you don't trust them
or they're just not very led not on your
level I don't know I don't feel that way
but I haven't felt that way you see if
you've had a good a good string of luck
with with the guys you work yeah or I
insist on it
I impose my will on you and you and make
you condition you to know that you're
going at some point you're going to have
to help me and you will
otherwise I'll punch you in the
esophageal I'm for any given Sunday is
no we don't tell us your smack is so
fresh i think jamie foxx when you're
that you're the magician sports TV is
and you're like you're just like
completely sucking his ass because he's
successful where you weren't before well
I was wrong for gym let me hang out with
him for about a couple of weeks and then
I went so I wanted that guy to be a
combination of Lenny Bruce and so I went
to what was then the Museum of Broadcast
now you could just get it on your
computer but I went to see a bunch of
different Lenny Bruce stuff at the
Museum of Broadcast and then I hung out
with Jim and I kind of found this
amalgamation of Lenny Bruce and Jim Rome
who was all the rage at the time and
that's who I brought down to Miami and
that's Oliver was just like yeah
McKinley do that no that'll be good
don't [ __ ] my film but do that see a
pretty intense can i I've interviewed
him once I don't know at all but he
seems like a pretty intense guy to work
for yes and he knows look when you're on
an oliver film it's tantamount to being
with a thoroughbred at kentucky the
kentucky rivers where they wear those
blinders creatively Oliver's vision has
blinders on and if you can fit in inside
that vision its nirvana if you want to
function outside
that's when actors have the nightmare
stories because it's Oliver's that we're
doing Oliver's film this is not kumbaya
let's all hold hands around the campfire
this is Oliver's film he wrote him he
probably worked on it for 10 years
we're gonna fit inside this this narrow
creative vision
that's his because it's his movie and
yes we're collaborating but stay inside
his creative vision if you stay in there
it's heaven if you want to function
outside of it you'll get run over well
he tried to bring you back in gently at
first or is he a guy who just is very
cut and dry what'd he want yeah well
there was no tie as you probably know on
movie sets there's no time everything we
have to go now we have to get this and
so no Oliver can can direct with a
sledgehammer at times do you get
frustrated when people can't
or don't work well in those
circumstances you know when that sort of
rush and pressures on and this and that
and they're kind of like ah you know
they like things to be a little bit
nicer a little bit softer does that
become very very difficult for you yes
it drives me insane
it does yep so what actors have when we
were doing scrubs we're describes for
about nine years and the small version
of a script which is about the
dimensions of a of a napkin from a
restaurant are called sides sure so
actors bring their sides on the set
until the last minute they're there
looking at them and then they put them
down and they they do the scene and so a
lot of times because actors are
struggling with lines right up until the
last second they got them right up by
their face and so I got so fed up with
actors not knowing the lines on Scrubs I
used to tell them you know what when we
come around to your shot keep this keep
the sides right in your face because
we're not gonna use yours he's gonna cut
to me listening it'll be infinitely
infinitely more interesting than you
struggling over your god damn lines and
they'd be like what like yeah you don't
need to just keep the sides in the frame
it'll be great just keep them right here
and because we're not gonna use your
coverage we're gonna cut to me going
like hmm oh that's more interesting than
listen needed listening to you struggle
for your goddamn lines and it's like a
subversive thing to do but I got so fed
up with people struggling for it's not
that hard to remember your goddamn line
call the reverse do you have that moment
where like where the way they're looking
at you trying to figure out oh is he
joking or yes and then they look at you
and realize you're not joking yes it's
just and that's how I like taking candy
from are you talking about people are
coming on it's guest spots right you
know the ensemble cast ensemble was I
work on a summer doing punch-up on a
movie of summer and some of the takes
you're going holy [ __ ] this is they're
doing all these takes you know just
saying this angle and the money that
they're for what this is this is just
two actors talking yeah yeah they do a
lot of takes
Woody Allen won't Woody Allen will do
what three takes to order you works with
Woody Allen oh I wish okay so you sure
on that so there absolutely you have the
say myself oh I work with Adam who's the
nicest guy in a plan oh the nicest and
ad-libbing and Sam without but you see
sometimes actors didn't have the [ __ ]
lines and they're throwing them the
lines and you know and hey as a punch-up
guy Who am I to say anything you know
yes you shall wish you felt that way now
yeah thank you I feel what he's saying
right I get it but you're not taught by
somebody like the first time that
somebody you talk about after three or
four takes where they're just not
getting what they're supposed to be
doing they're screwing everything up yes
yeah that's frustrating yeah what are we
doing did you read this group what are
we doing here yeah yeah this isn't brain
surgery that's gotta be the worst
feeling too when you have such a great
kid there's nothing they can say like
you're right right no use if anybody
what are they gonna say like ah McKinley
doesn't know he's talking about you like
I have anybody knows what they're
talking about it just I'll be with ya
probably him yeah it's probably the guy
definitely do ya check his resume hey
when you were on dude were you on the
set of Wall Street did you have to
interact with Martin Sheen at all no you
didn't now but no he was on though he
had those Hospital interiors I was just
in that one interior just not trading
floor
we never I saw Marvin the that character
never left the trading floor where's
that based on anybody it was based on
Oliver's experience with his father was
a financier and so I think it was
Oliver's it was who's Stanley Weiser
wrote the script and so and then Oliver
tweaked it and I think he brought a lot
of his sensibilities growing up as the
son of a financier on the Upper East
Side
so it was a work of fiction
there was loosely based on like an Ivan
Boesky type character Gordon Gekko yes
do you do when you're getting like when
you have a guy like Oliver who obviously
likes you and wants you as his guy in a
lot of the character roles in his movies
do you ever after whatever two three
four movies stop him and be like Oliver
like you have anything more like a like
a bigger role you have a starring thing
or do you go like no this is my spot
this is this is what I'm good at and
in this I kind of stay in my lane yeah
especially with somebody like Oliver
who's you know if somebody puts you in
six movies I don't know if there's a
whole lot of complaining in there right
and so no from from platoon to any given
Sunday that's a good run and I haven't
seen Oliver in years but want to do and
we get back in the cockpit it'll be like
I'm sure it'll be just like falling out
of bed sure the same thing you just pick
right up where you left off I think so
that's been my experience going from
each film to the next now we did talk
radio for a year and a half as the play
before Oliver came in and decided to do
the movie so it was one of those rare
occasions usually when someone does the
play the conventional wisdom is it's
called star [ __ ] we're gonna start
[ __ ] somebody for your role we're gonna
get sure a big bigger name than McKinley
to play the character's name was Stu to
play the guy in the box and we'll star
[ __ ] somebody and the fact that I got to
create that character and then do the
movie is against all odds you just don't
you get replaced ya by whoever the
character actor is of the day who's
gonna slum down a little bit John
Travolta is going to place too
and so I got to do that and that felt
really good we were just watching you
yesterday we were talking about because
yeah I mean you really I mean you and
your you and Tom Berenger in platoon
like I mean what a he's that character
of Sergeant Barnes was it's one of the
greatest movie characters ever and you
got to do most of your scenes with him
yeah and before I left I decided that
what would the one thing the character I
was playing is a guy named sergeant
O'Neill and the one thing I was gonna do
was for that character arc was whatever
it took to get the [ __ ] out of here for
the carrier and the way to get out of
here was through Tom's was through
sergeant Barnes there's no way out
except for food
so John McKinley I became best friends
with Tom and then the trickle down from
that look every time you get in front of
a lens you're lying and so if you can
reduce the scope of the lie the length
of the lie in front of a lens you have a
chance of telling the story and maybe
this lens doesn't suffer you as the lie
is so profound and so if I
become best friends with Tom Berenger
and then that bleeds into the way
sergeant O'Neal and sergeant Barnes
treat and regard each other we're
reducing the space of the lie and it
works and so that's what I did I became
friend best friends with Tom he happens
to be the greatest guy in a planet and
then that the lens picked that up and
the only way out for O'Neal was through
Barnes and then when Barnes dies and and
O'Neal gets reassigned the platoon
there's that great shot at the end where
he's just [ __ ] he did everything he
could to get out of here
and he couldn't well Barnes wouldn't let
you out correct that I mean that was a
really harsh scene just just you begging
this guy with the whole film you've been
good to beg yeah we there's this great
whimpering yeah whatever took Al's got
that great line in any given Sunday
whatever it takes and there throughout
the whole film one gesture I thought to
be a real the the supplicant of the king
would be to always be lighting a
cigarette yes at all times and there's
that one great scene in the beginning
where Willems in the scene and Mark
Moses the lieutenant and and we're
sitting around and we're gonna get a
sign the night operation the night up
and Tom takes a cigarette out and I
could see him I in my periphery and I
wanted to do a magic Johnson Pete
Maravich no-look light and I did and but
the the Zippo didn't ignite and so I
felt the whole scene stopped and
everyone's looking at me and then I look
over at Tom and and I lit it for him
that's the one Oliver put the film that
was the one he canceled out today it's
the again there was the lie got reduced
there was no there was I was horrified
but the one thing I was gonna [ __ ] do
was always be lighting this guy
cigarette and I thought it'd be a little
sexy about it and do a no-look and you
know like a Magic Johnson no look yeah
and so I did a no-look light and I felt
Willem looking at me mark Moses and I'm
like I didn't have a line so I was just
wondering what goddamnit the cool thing
did not work out or so not cool yeah not
even
and watch that scene again you'll see
what I mean